la mode donne chaque saison une nouvelle
silhouette à la femme toutes les femmes
peuvent suivre cette mode est élégante
même avec un modeste budget comment en
confectionnant elles-mêmes leurs
toilettes
les deux jeunes femmes qui descendent de
cette voiture ont exécuté l'europe
d'après des patrons fabriquées en
bretagne châtelaudren
nous allons suivre avec elles les
différentes étapes de la fabrication de
ses patrons même comment sont créés ces
modèles est bien à chaque saison c'est
la haute couture qui lance la mode et
nous partons des tendances qui sont
donnés par la boue couture et nous avons
environ 15 des listes extérieures à
notre maison qui nous apportent leur
création ils nous approvisionnent
environ en 2 4 milles modèle pour chaque
collection que nous avons à créer les
collections se compose d'environ 450
modèle donc nous partons de 4000 modèles
pour en tirer quatre cent cinquante
rencontres choisir vraiment le meilleur
oui inspiré et créé à paris les derniers
modèles aux lignes nouvelles sont
envoyés à châtelaudren pour la
fabrication des patrons les collections
sont renouvelés trois fois par an une
fois pour l'été une fois pour l'automne
hiver et une fois pour le printemps la
collection d'été est mise en route dès
le mois de décembre
il faut distinguer la fabrication de la
pochette est celle du patron proprement
dit
le dessin de la pochette où figure le
modèle est reproduit dans un atelier de
photogravure c'est dans cet atelier
également que sont sélectionnés les
couleurs parallèlement à cette opération
il faut également faire une place au
texte destiné à guider celles qui auront
à utiliser les patrons le cliché réalisé
permet d'obtenir le relief ou si vous
préférez la copie sur rails
c'est cette matrice il sert à
l'impression de centaines de milliers de
pochettes dont celle madame qui sera
peut-être vol à bord
le patron est réalisé dans un autre
atelier le papier de soie fin doit être
découpée selon les différentes parties
du modèle les patrons sont découpées par
500 à la fois la réalisation comprend le
découpage le père forage du papier tout
cela sera vérifiée afin d'éviter tout
intersection du patron qui entraînerait
des difficultés pour l'utilisatrice
cette vérification ainsi fait permet le
pliage dernière opération avant la mise
sous pochette du patron la re de
patronner existe les fils au siècle
dernier mais j'imagine qu'elle a dû
subir de nombreuses transformations
effectivement elle a subi de nombreuses
transformations puisqu'à l'origine
remonte à 1885 et l'époque laissé des
patrons et tp est effectué sur mesure et
puis les placeront sont tous des coupés
l'issue prochaine
c'est l'année depuis 1915 environ et
votre production et notre solution de
battement était environ 6 millions par
an vous employez en grande proportion
des femmes sont elles dans la fille du
patron pour le pillage des patrons
vingt-et-une personnes et dans
l'ensemble de l'entreprise spirou 50 %
de femmes ils vont en partie la
population féminine de gfl ou drogue
je vois que c'est plié dans une grande
dextérité comment sont-elles formés et
bien défi lieux sont formés dans nos
ateliers
c'est un travail extrêmement délicat
elles ont la formation et le pays 2
demande environ deux ans et elle s'y
combien de patriarche ou une vie
heureuse
cette personne est extrêmement rapide
livres environ 2000 patrons temps mais à
votre avis qu'est-ce qui attire la
clientèle vers la mode patronné et bien
je pense qu'il y a deux choses je pense
qu'il ya d'abord un souci d'économie qui
n'est peut-être pas le plus important
mais qui joue conte et puis le deuxième
souci je pense c'est que à travers le
patron la femme peut exprimer son goût
personnel et je crois que la femme
française aime bien exprimer son vous à
travers des modèles qu'elle arrageois de
réaliser les ailes net
voilà donc ce qui vous permettra à
madame de réaliser selon votre goût
la robe ou la toilette de votre choix
pour s'impliquer encore cette tâche il
vous est recommandé de vous conformer
aux explications clairement indiqué aux
côtés du dessin sans trop de frais la
mode est par ce moyen à la portée de la
main alors voyez vous en principe sur le
plan de la rochette la fin de tout de
suite voici c'est un modèle qu'elle est
capable de réaliser
elle voit les futurs elle voit les
pinces elle c'est à l'avant si c'est un
modèle qui est à sa portée
la deuxième chose est que sur chacune
des pièces des numéros sur neuf
et à l'intérieur de la pochette avec le
patron il est un petit texte explicatif
la première chose à faire est donc
lorsque vous avez utilisé votre tissu en
tenant compte du métrage indiqué de
déplier les pièces du patron ou les
disposer sur le vif alors là nous allons
poser le vélo ou en faisant très
attention aux volumes de droit fil qui
sont habillés par l'exploration le
robert que nous venons et par rapport à
la ligne
pas trop va toujours être parallèle
analyser avec qui on aimerait disposer
la manche
montrez-moi autrement je vous reviens
là même où il faut les assez large du
parti ce qu'elles écrivent dans un
poignet nous avons ici disposer le
poignet c'est ce numéro 11 heures
disposées ici le col qui est droit fil
de l'eau que nous allons reporter
puisqu'il nous faut allier 4 froid comme
c'est indiqué dans votre texte alors sur
votre qui suit vous allez sans doute
fait ce mouvement de façon à avoir
l'autre moitié du col nos pièces sont
maintenant ce procès je pense qu'il est
nécessaire de faire un dernier contrôle
avec le plan pour vous assurer qu'il n'y
a pas de problème qu'on n'a pas oublié
laissait les valeurs de couture et après
mon dieu la stupeur prend son courage à
couper le tissu précieux malgré les
avantages du prêt à porter le patron
reste pour le très nombreuses femmes le
moyen de garder une marque personnelle
et l'originalité de la toilette
l'imprimerie de châtelaudren fourni
plusieurs marques de patron elle
correspond à peu près à la moitié de la
production française en amérique on vend
un patron par tête d'habitant
or en france ont tout de même les femmes
sont extrêmement à droite et m la
couture je crois et aime l'élégance
cette fameuse élégance de paris est bien
une vente dont pour l'instant un patron
pour six habitants seulement donc une
pensons que la marge entre un par
habitant et un pour six habitants nous
laisse beaucoup d'espoir